california voters are deciding whether
governor gavin newsom should keep his
job newsom is asking big names in his
own party to push democrats to vote
before the polls close tuesday in that
recall election there and while recent
polls seem to be in newsome's favor as
carter evans reports his campaign is not
leaving it to chance
your vote could be the difference
between protecting our kids and putting
them at risk helping californians
recover or taking us backwards former
president barack obama is now joining
democratic allies in the fight to keep
governor gavin newsom in office in an ad
released wednesday the former president
praised newsome's pandemic response but
with having had some of the strictest
lockdown measures in the country it's
become a key issue for both sides of the
recall campaign how do you plan to vote
i'm going to vote for the recall why
i've not been particularly happy with
the governor's performance and i think
he could have done better on the covet
frankly a third of all small businesses
are now gone forever because he refused
to allow us to use our own common sense
our own good judgment republican front
runner and talk radio host larry elder
says he'll repeal mask and vaccine
mandates
he was heckled by homeless advocates
wednesday one of whom threw an egg at
the candidate during an la campaign stop
elder is currently leading the nearly
four dozen candidates both republican
and democrat donors have spent millions
on the recall but newsome's backers have
raised almost double the amount of all
of his opponents now democrats say
energizing people to actually get out
and vote is key to a win on tuesday now
that they started to see and research
like who is actually trying to become
the new governor they got a little
freaked out and now they're voting
well this is one of the ballot drop-off
locations in napa valley here the only
successful california recall was in 2003
when actor arnold schwarzenegger
replaced governor gray davis now on
tuesday if more than 50 percent of
voters approve the recall then the
candidate with the most votes wins so
think about that the next governor of
california could be chosen with a very
small fraction of the votes gail
it's fascinating and we are all watching
thank you very much carter